PROFESSOR: Do them individually
so I can continue
to put names and
faces together.
I'm happy to announce that
the registrar has now got
everybody's photograph
online for
registration in the course.
So anonymity is a thing of the
past, so you have to watch
your step from now on.
I handed back, to those who
didn't get it, problem set
number four, which asked you
to tackle some patterns,
nontrivial patterns.
And actually, that was a dirty
trick, because we hadn't, at
that point, derived the plane
groups, and you really didn't
know what to do or
what to look for.
But nevertheless, it got you
thinking about patterns and
some of the symmetry elements
which we had discussed up to
that point.
At this point we have derived
exhaustively every last one of
the 17 plane groups.
So now you are armed with this
new-found power, and when
faced with a pattern, you should
know exactly what to
look for and how to go
about deciding what
plane group it is.
At the very least, you'll
have the drawings of the
arrangement of symmetry elements
in the plane groups
before you, and you can work by
the process of elimination.
For example, high symmetry
usually hits you right between
the eyes, and if something is
square-ish, you can pretty
quickly guess that it's based
on a square lattice.
And if it has a square lattice,
there jolly well
better be a 4-fold axis in there
that makes it square.
If you can find the 4-fold axis,
then you have to ask
yourself only three questions.
So 4-fold axis, fine.
Is there a mirror
line in there?
Yeah.
Does the mirror line go through
the 4-fold axis?
Then it is P 4 MM.
And you know just where to
look for everything else,
including these very
subtle glide planes
that are hard to spot.
If there is a mirror plane
there, but it doesn't go
through the 4-fold axis,
then it's P 4 MG.
And if there is no mirror
plane, then it's P 4.
So just by asking one or two
simple questions, you can
narrow it down to what the
plane group has to be.
This is another indication that
the informed intellect is
always more than a match
for sheer, raw native
intelligence.
If you know what to look
for, it's a lot easier.
Because you really didn't have
much practice with patterns,
we're having a quiz, as you
know, next Thursday, that will
cover up through completion of
the plane groups and not the
material we've been doing now.
So I think it might be of use
to you to have some practice
analyzing a few more patterns.
So there are four additional
patterns in this problem set.
As always, it's optional, but if
you would like to try them,
and you want to see if you've
got them right, come in and
see me tomorrow or on
Thursday morning.
I'd be happy to go over them
with you on the spot.
So this is for practice.
And some of you did
extraordinarily well
on the first try.
Others, I think, could use
the additional practice.
There were a few people who
identified the plane group
correctly, but got the name
that's assigned to it wrong.
And one other very confusing
thing is that there is one
plane group that has the symbols
G and M, and another
plane group which has
the symbols M and G.
So if you found a mirror plane
and a glide plane is an
independent symmetry plane,
when is it MG,
and when is it GM?
I have a little mnemonic
device.
GM, general manager, is the
guy who sits on top of the
organization.
So GM should be the
plane group that
has the highest symmetry.
P 4 GM, P 4 general manager.
Now that is--
hey, it works for me.
But another way of saying it
is that there are two plane
groups, one has MG and the other
has GM, and I like cars,
and I think an MG is much
classier than anything that
General Motors, GM, puts out,
so MG should be the one of
highest quality, highest
symmetry.
And that's just the reverse.
But whatever works for you.
You could keep them straight
through that simple algorithm.
And as they say, if it works for
me, but if it doesn't work
for you, don't use it.
All right.
What I will bring in during
intermission, for those of you
had trouble identifying
translations in the patterns
that we handed out earlier, I've
taken these and put them
on overhead transparencies.
And I'll have two of each.
So if you don't see the symmetry
or translations that
are present, you can actually
take one pattern and
physically move it and lay it
on top of the other one, and
that's a good way to convince
yourself what a translation
looks like when it occurs
in a pattern.
So I'll bring those in at
our break between class.
All right, any questions
before we move on?
Any questions that have arisen
as you have gotten
ready for the quiz?
You haven't gotten ready
for the quiz yet, so
there are no questions.
That's OK.
I know how things work at MIT.
You deal with one crisis
at a time.
Any questions?
Anything you want to go over?
There was one interesting
wrinkle in a problem that I
had not encountered before,
and this was the one that
asked you to look at, in two
dimensions, a plane with
indices h and k.
And then, when h and k were
mutually prime, to move that
plane by the translations plus
T1 and plus and minus T2, and
then show that the number of
intervals between the origin
and the intercept plane, the one
that hit lattice points on
both translations, was equal
to h times k if they were
mutually prime.
That is true only if the
lattice is primitive.
And what the problem said was to
pick one of the cells that
you used in the first
problem, number one.
Well, that problem asked you
to begin with identifying
different primitive cells.
If you take a multiple cell,
this operation of going plus
and minus T1 does not put a
lattice line through each of
the lattice points.
If you picked a double cell,
that process decorated only
half of the lattice points with
planes, and the other
half sat there with nothing
hanging on them at all.
The key to the difference, if
you looked at a double cell,
was that if h plus k was even,
then you automatically got a
plane on every lattice point.
If h plus k was odd, as it would
have been for the plane
2,1 for example, 2 plus 1 is 3--
hey, this isn't even one
of my good days--
then half of the lattice points
did not have planes
hanging on them.
Now, there's great relevance
of this observation to
diffraction, and you probably
are all familiar, if only
vaguely, with the magic rules
that say, if h plus k is equal
to 3 pi plus 4, then the
intensity is identically 0.
Well, for a double cell, the
lattice planes that are
repeated by translation diffract
x-rays, and there is
no reason why the intensity
should be
something other than 0.
So here comes, a la Bragg, an
x-ray beam coming in at angle
theta, and then you say you
get diffraction when
scattering from this lattice
plane is exactly in
phase with this one.
And this gives the familiar
relation that an integral
number of wavelengths is equal
to 2 d sine of theta when the
crystal diffracts.
So there is exactly-- this
says there's exactly 2 pi
phase difference or n lambda
path difference between these
two planes.
Now, if the lattice would be a
double cell, then there is an
additional lattice point in here
that does not get a plane
hung on it.
So if the lattice is a double
cell, there's another plane
that has to hang on this lattice
point, and that one is
exactly out of phase with this
plane, and the intensity is 0.
So this observation that a
non-primitive lattice has a
interplanar spacing that is a
sub-multiple of that of a
primitive lattice gives some
insight into why certain
reflections--
certain diffraction maxima-- are
identically 0 in intensity
for a crystal that has a
non-primitive lattice.
So that is something I had
not noticed before.
I should have, but I will phrase
the problem a little
bit more precisely
in the future.
All right.
So to conclude my preamble, I
hope you'll try playing with
some of the four additional
patterns that I handed out,
just to give yourself
some practice.
And the implication of this is
that you're going to see a
pattern on the quiz, and I will
tell you that you will.
So if you want to see how you
did on the patterns that I
distributed, please come in
and talk to me about them.
All right then.
Let me remind you where
we were last time.
We started to begin to build a
framework of symmetry elements
in three dimensions.
And we asked the question, what
would happen if we take a
first rotation axis, A alpha,
combine it with a second
rotation axis, B beta, in
such a way that they
intersect at a point.
This means that their operation
and reproducing
atoms or motifs is going to
leave at least one point in
space unchanged, and that will
be the point of intersection.
We ask ourselves, what will
be the combined effect--
we have two operations
in space--
what would be the combined
effect of rotating alpha
degrees about A followed
immediately by beta degrees
about B.
So what we're going to do then
is to take a first motif--
and let's say it's
left handed.
Being a left-handed person, I
like to give right handed
motifs and left handed
motifs equal time.
If we rotate that through an
angle alpha, and this is
number 2, it will stay
left handed.
Then if we rotate that by B
beta, it'll move it over here
to number 3 and it will stay
left handed as well.
And the question is then, what
net operation is equivalent to
the combined operation of these
two transformations?
And to specify the type of
operation is really a
no-brainer.
All of these motifs are of the
same corality so the only
thing that can relate them is
translation or another rotation.
And clearly the first and the
third have no reason to be
parallel to one another, and the
distance between them is
going to depend on how far they
are away from the axis,
so translation won't do the
job, a and the only thing
that's left as a net operation
that's equivalent to those two
steps is rotation about
a third axis C.
And what we're going to do today
is answer the question,
where is axis C located, and
what is the angle of rotation,
given the value of alpha and
beta and the angle between
these two axes?
And let's define that
as a lowercase c.
So clearly the location of the
axis and the amount of the
rotation is going to be a
function of alpha, beta, and
the angle between them.
We want this to be a combination
of operations that
exists in a symmetry
operation.
And if this is to be a
crystallographic symmetry,
these will be restricted to
the angular throws of a
1-fold, 2-fold, 3-fold,
4-fold, a 6-fold axis.
We can take these two at a time,
ask what the net effect
is if we combine at
a given angle c.
And what comes out here must
be a rotation which is also
crystallographic.
So there are going to be severe
constraints on this
combination.
Two rotations about an
intersecting point will always
be a third rotation, but if
this is to be a set of
operations in a symmetry group,
the result must be
crystallographic.
That's a tough problem, and how
will we undertake it is
going to be non-intuitive.
OK, the problem is most readily
treated with spherical
trigonometry.
So on the surface of a sphere,
I'm going to map the point at
which A alpha protrudes--
and I'll call this point A--
and then I'll mark out the point
where axis B beta exits
the sphere, and I'll mark that
point B. And this is the angle
C.
And we said that in spherical
trigonometry, the measure of
the length of the arc separating
A and B is given by
the angle subtended at the
center, so the length of this
distance between A and
B is the angle c.
Again, it sort of boggles the
mind when you measure lengths
in terms of degrees rather
than some metric unit.
All right.
So I will now not bother to show
the sphere on which the
geometry is taking place.
I'll just draw A and B,
and this is the arc
between them, c.
And somewhere or other there
will be some third axis, C,
which is going to be the
combined effect of the
rotation about axis A and axis
B. So what I would like to do
is to locate the position
of this axis C.
In order to do that, I'll have
to know what the angle between
A and C is, and I'll call that,
by analogy to what I've
done here, I'll call that b.
And I'll want to know what the
angle between B and C is, and
I'll call that angle a.
So again, going back to three
dimensions momentarily, if
this is the rotation operation
C gamma, and this is A alpha,
and this is B beta, the axis c
is this, the angle b is this,
and the angle a is this.
OK.
It's a non-trivial problem and
it is not by accident that the
solution to this problem was
first given by a very, very
famous mathematician, Leonhard
Euler, and this construction
that we're about to go through
is called Euler's
construction.
All right.
Let me find where these
different locations
are going to be.
We've specified the location of
point A and the location of
point B, and we know that the
angle between them is the
length of the arc ab, which is
the angle between A and C. So
let me now do some
constructions.
Let me find a great circle that
by design is alpha over 2
away from the arc ab, and
that is by construction.
And I'm going to say, then, that
if A alpha works in this
direction, the operation of A
alpha is going to take this
great circle and move it over
to a great circle which is
alpha over 2 on the other
side of the arc ab.
Fine, you say, so what?
Well, just going to leave
those there for now.
I'll have B beta work
in the same sense.
And I'm now going to create a
line here that by construction
is beta over 2 on one side of
the arc ab, and if I let B
beta go to work, that will map
this great circle over to a
new location beta over
2 on the other side.
What has this done for me, other
than perhaps confuse me
and clutter the diagram?
Well, now I'm going to determine
unequivocally the
location of the axis C, and
where it emerges from the
reference here.
And how will I do that?
I'm going to use a definition
that may have seemed trivial
the first time we made
the observation.
I said that a symmetry element
is the locus of points that is
left unmoved by an operation.
OK?
I rotated by A alpha from here
to here, that took everything
along this line and mapped it
to a new location here.
I took this line and rotated
it by B beta, and that took
everything along this line and
moved it to a new location.
So my question now is if I
rotate by A alpha and then
rotate in the same direction
by B beta, what
point is left unmoved?
It's only one point that can
make that claim, and that is
where these two great
circles intersect.
The rotation A alpha will
take this location--
and I'm going to call it C
because I've identified now
what it is-- it's going to take
C and move it over to
here, call that C prime, and
then B beta takes that point
and only that point, and
restores it back to its
original location.
So this, then, ladies and
gentlemen, is where the
rotation axis C gamma pokes
out of the sphere of
reflection.
Still don't know what this angle
is in here, and I would
dearly love to know what these
arcs b and a are, and then I
will have specified all three
of the interaxial angles
between A, B and C.
OK, let me do something quite
similar to what I did before.
I'm going to again let A alpha
work on a particular point,
and then let B beta map it.
So here's A alpha,
here's B beta.
And now I'm going to look
specifically at how these two
rotations transform point A,
where A is the point at which
axis A alpha pokes out
of the sphere.
A alpha, when it acts on this
point, does nothing to it.
It leaves it alone.
B beta is going to map A to
a new location, A prime.
Now, doing A alpha and following
up by B beta is
supposed to be equal to
the rotation C gamma.
So that says that this point and
this point must be related
by the rotation gamma.
So say that again.
We're doing exactly what we did
here except we're starting
with an initial point, not this
arc, but we're starting
with the specific point A,
operate on it by A alpha, it
twirled around but stays put.
Rotate that by B beta, it goes
through a total angle beta to
this location here.
The net effect of getting from A
to A prime is supposed to be
the rotation C gamma, so this
angle is then gamma and this
is the location of C. OK?
OK, one other step that's
a fairly easy one.
This length is equal to this
length, because they were
produced by rotation.
This side is common to these two
triangles, and this angle
then is beta over 2, this
is beta over 2.
And if these two triangles, A,
B, and C, that triangle is
similar to A prime BC, and
therefore I can say that angle
A prime CA is identical to ACB,
so therefore this angle
has to equal this angle, and if
the total angle is gamma,
this is gamma over 2, and
this is gamma over 2.
So now let me extract from this
the information that I
would like to use.
Here are three axes, A alpha,
B beta, and C gamma.
This angle in here
is gamma over 2.
This angle in here is beta over
2, and this angle in here
is alpha over 2.
And let me emphasize that in
this magic triangle, out of
which we're going to extract
some dazzlingly profound
stuff, it is half the angular
throw of the rotation axes
that appear in here as these
spherical angles, and not the
entire angle of rotation.
So here's how properties of the
three rotation axes are
related one to another.
And now, we introduced without
proof last time something
called the law of cosines in
spherical trigonometry.
And I not only do not want to
prove it, but I have no idea
how I would go about doing so,
but that doesn't prevent me
from using it.
So if here are three edges, a,
b, c, and three angles in
there, A, B, and C, we said
that the law of cosines in
spherical trigonometry,
analogous in a way to the law
of cosines and plane geometry,
except since the lengths of
the triangles are measured
in degrees, there are
trigonometric functions of these
angles that appear in
the law of cosines.
This says that cosine of b
cosine of c plus sine b sine
of c times cosine of a is
equal to cosine of a.
So this now is an interesting
relation that we can apply to
this spherical triangle, which
connects together the three
rotation axes.
Let me apply it to find the
angle c which we have picked
as the angle between the initial
two axes a and b.
That says that this should be
equal to cosine of b cosine of
c, the angle between the other
two axes, plus sine of b sine
of c times the cosine of angle
a, and angle a is cosine of
alpha over 2.
So all these quantities that
we'd like to determine are
hooked together by the
law of cosines.
And this is a lovely relation,
but it doesn't do us a bit of
good, because in this relation
we know only one quantity, and
that is the rotation
angle of a.
We can pick the angle between
a and b, that's this, but I
have no idea what these
other angles are.
That's what I'd like
to find out.
I'd like to find out the
angles at which three
rotations have to be combined
in order that rotation about
one followed by rotation about
the second be the third.
So this equation is a beautiful
equation, but it
involves everything that I
don't know and only one
quantity that I do know.
So it looks as though
we're up the creek.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: So you're looking for
cosine c, so shouldn't it
be cosine b cosine a?
PROFESSOR: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah, I did that wrong.
Yeah.
You're absolutely right.
This should be cosine of a,
and this a goes with this
alpha over 2.
Absolutely.
Sorry about that.
So anyway, the point still
stands that what this equation
involves is the three interaxial
angles, and I would
like to know how I could combine
a and b to get it to
come out to a crystallographic
rotation c, and where that
location is relative to
the first two axes.
So it involves everything I
don't know, and only one
thing that I do.
But now we introduce another
curious aspect of spherical
triangles, which I mentioned
last time.
You may have thought
that that's
interesting, but who cares?
Here are the three points, A,
B, and C, and these are the
three arcs little c, little
a and little b.
And then we said we could
construct something called the
polar triangle of ABC.
And what we would do, we would
find the pole of arc b, and
that will be some
point B prime.
We'll find the pole of arc
a, and that will be
some point A prime.
We'll find, similarly, the pole
of arc c, and that will
be some point C prime.
And now we can connect together
A prime, B prime, and
C prime, and get something
that's
called the polar triangle.
And now comes the useful part.
We said that a curious property
of the polar triangle
is that the side of the polar
triangle plus the angle
opposite it add up
to 180 degrees.
In my original triangle, this is
beta over 2, this is gamma
over 2, and this is
alpha over 2.
So the length of this side is
going to be 180 degrees minus
beta over 2, the length of this
side is going to be 180
degrees minus alpha over 2, and
the length of this side is
going to be 180 degrees
minus gamma over 2.
And now let's use these angles
and these lengths in the law
of cosines, and I'll leave
out the little bit
of intervening algebra.
And what we will get out of
this is that cosine of c--
and I'll solve for that--
is equal to cosine of alpha over
2 cosine of beta over 2
plus cosine of gamma over 2
divided by sine alpha over 2
sine beta over 2.
And that is something we can
sink our teeth into and run
with, because now I can ask the
question, suppose I want a
to be a 2-fold rotation axis,
b to be a 3-fold rotation
axis, and c be a 4-fold
rotation axis?
Then the value of alpha over 2
is half of 180 degrees or 90.
Well, you can see I put
in half the value of
the rotation axes.
And then I solve for c, and that
is the angle at which I
have to put axis a and b
together to get c to turn out
to be whatever angle
gamma over 2 is.
So I can do this
systematically now without thinking.
And I can set up the problem by
taking the crystallographic
rotation axes and combining them
together three at a time
in all possible combinations.
Right?
In addition to this relation,
I have two other relations.
And let me assemble them off to
the left, because we have
to solve three equations to
find out the nature of the
combination that is required.
So just permuting terms, the
angle between A and B, c, has
to follow from cosine of c
equals cosine of alpha over 2
cosine of beta over 2 plus
cosine of gamma over 2.
Notice that the single term by
itself is the cosine of half
the angle of the opposite
rotation axis c.
Then in the denominator is the
sine of these two angles.
And so just permuting terms, one
can see that cosine of b
is going to turn out to be
cosine of alpha over 2 cosine
of gamma over 2 plus cosine of
theta over 2 divided by sine
of alpha over 2 sine
of gamma over 2.
And a third analogous expression
will give me the
angle that will be the one
between B and C. And this will
be cosine of beta over 2 cosine
gamma over 2 plus
cosine of alpha over 2 divided
by sine beta over 2
sine gamma over 2.
OK?
So now we don't have
to think anymore.
It's just plug and chug.
And I'll pause to suck in air
and let you catch up, and then
we'll set up the problem and
look at a few solutions.
And all this, in the event
that you're thoroughly
bewildered, is in the
set of notes that I
handed out last time.
So you can read it over
at your leisure.
AUDIENCE: Will this stuff
be on the quiz?
PROFESSOR: No.
Quiz will go up to the end of
the two-dimensional plane
groups and stop.
We won't say anything
three dimensional.
OK, let's, then, if there's no
objection or complaint, look
at possible values for--
let me do it the same way that
I did it in the notes so that
it's consistent--
let's put down the value for
axis b, the rank of axis b and
the rank of axis a.
And A could be a 1-fold axis,
B could be a 1-fold access,
and we could take a 1 with a 1
with a 1, a 1 with a 1 with a
2, a 1 with a 1 with a 3, a 1
with a 1 with a 4, and a 1
with a 1 with a 6.
This is clearly impossible.
If I did nothing, and followed
it by doing nothing, and
wanted it to come out to be a
6-fold rotation, you'd all be
spinning on your axes
like tops right now.
So you can't do nothing and
follow it by doing nothing and
have it come out to
be a net rotation.
So these are impossible.
So we don't have to
consider those.
A could be a 2, though, and I
don't want to do 2, 1, 1,
because I've got
a 1, 1, 2 here.
The order doesn't make
any difference.
So I'll start with a 2, 1,
2, a 2, 1, 3, a 2, 1,
4, and a 2, 1, 6.
So those are four combinations
that I should be examining.
I could look at a 3 with a--
2 with a 1, I have here in the
form of 2, 1, 3, so the next
one I would want to look at
is a 3, 1, 3, a 3, 1,
4, and a 3, 1, 6.
And let me put in a
couple more here.
If B were a 2, I should look at
a 2 with a 2 with a 2, a 2
with a 2 with a 3, a 2
with a 2 with a 4, 2
with a 2 with a 6.
And then A 3 with a 2--
and I've got 3, 2, 2 up here, so
I'll start with 3, 2, 3, 3,
2, 4, 3, 2, 6, run out of room
here, but there should be a
similar entry with
a 4 and a 6.
So this sets up the problem.
If you count up the number of
ways one can do this, we only
have to consider the
off-diagonal boxes here,
because interchanging a and b,
for example, looking at 3, 1,
3, that's going to be the
same as 1, 3, 3 up here.
So it's just the off-diagonal
boxes
that we have to consider.
So there should be a 3,
3, 3 in here, a 3, 3,
4, and a 3, 3, 6.
So what we would have to do in
order to determine the unique
combinations is to look at all
of these combinations in turn,
and I'm going to not
try all of them.
I will do one that's going
to be clearly impossible.
So let's look at 2, 1, 4.
So here A corresponds to a
2-fold axis, B corresponds to
a 1-fold axis, and C would
correspond to a 4-fold axis.
So could we combine these three
axes at appropriate
angles such that a 2-fold
followed by a 1-fold is
equivalent to a 4-fold?
This clearly isn't
going to work.
If I do a 180-degree rotation
then don't do anything and ask
is that equivalent to a 4-fold
rotation, that is saying that
the 2-fold axis should be
identical to the 4-fold axis,
and that is not going to work.
So let me do now a generic
family that I know turns out
to be possible.
Let me look at an n-fold axis
with a 2-fold axis with a
2-fold axis, and I can show
that this combination is
possible for any integer
n whatsoever.
So this will include a lot
of non-crystallographic
symmetries.
So let's say that this is C,
this is A, and this is B. But
make it C, B, A if you'd like.
OK, so my first equation says
that cosine of c, the angle
between A and B, should be equal
to the cosine of alpha
over 2 times the cosine of beta
over 2 plus the cosine of
gamma over 2 divided by sine
of alpha over 2 sine
of beta over 2.
B is a 2-fold axis, so alpha
is equal to 180 degrees.
A is a 2-fold--
I'm sorry.
B beta, A alpha.
Beta is equal to 180 degrees,
the angular
throw of a 2-fold axis.
Alpha is equal to 180
degrees, the angular
throw of a 2-fold axis.
And gamma is equal to whatever
2 pi over n would be.
That's the throw of the n-fold
axis than I'm letting be equal
to C.
So the cosine of A and B, to get
the result of rotation A
followed by rotation B being
equal to the net rotation of
an n-fold axis is that the
cosine of c should be the
cosine of 180 degrees over 2
times the cosine of 180 over 2
plus the cosine of gamma over
2, and gamma is whatever the
rank of the axis determines, and
that's divided by sine of
alpha over 2, and alpha is 180
and sine beta over 2, and
that's 180 over 2.
So the cosine of c is going to
be the cosine of 90, which is
0, times the cosine of 90, which
is 0, plus the cosine of
gamma over 2, whatever that
might be, over the sine of 90
which is 1, sine of
90 which is 1.
So this says that cosine
of c is equal to cosine
of gamma over 2.
So the angle between axis A and
axis B ought to be equal
to one half the angular throw
of rotation axis C. So let's
start putting down some
of this information.
This says that if this is axis
C gamma, then A pi and B pi,
the 2 180-degree rotations,
should be at an
angle gamma over 2.
We still need values
for b, and we still
need a value for a.
So let's find out
what those are.
And let me start over here at
the left again, because I've
got the relation that I need
for b sitting here.
The cosine of b is equal to the
cosine of alpha over 2,
and that is the cosine of pi
over 2, plus alpha is a
90-degree rotation.
Then cosine of gamma over 2,
whatever gamma happens to be,
plus the cosine of beta over
2, and that's cosine of pi
over 2, and this is all over
sine of pi over 2 times the
sine of gamma over 2.
So this is going to be cosine of
pi over 2, which is 0, plus
cosine of pi over 2 divided by
sine of pi over 2, which is 1.
This gamma over 2--
no, cosine of pi over 2 is 0.
So this is 0 plus 0 times sine
of gamma over 2, whatever that
turns out to be.
So cosine of b is 0, and that
says that the angle b between
axis A and axis C turns
out to be 90 degrees.
So in order to get pi followed
by c gamma to be equal to b
pi, I've got to make b be
equal to pi over 2.
And if I put it in this
orientation, then a pi
followed by c gamma is going
to be equal to b pi.
One final angle, and that's
the value for a.
OK, cosine of a should be equal
to the cosine of beta
over 2, that's pi over 2 times
the cosine of gamma over 2,
whatever it is, plus the cosine
of beta over 2, and
that's cosine of pi over 2, over
sine pi over 2 sine of
gamma over 2.
And this, as for b, turns out
to be 0 plus 0 over sine pi
over 2, which is 1 times
sine of gamma over 2.
So cosine of a turns out to be
0, and this says that the
angle a is also pi over 2.
So we've got a whole--
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Did you really
need to go
through all three equations?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, because I had
to show that all three work.
And in general, if I combine,
let's say, a 4-fold with a
3-fold with a 2-fold, which is
something I want to do, all
three angles a, b, and
c, will be different.
OK?
So the answer is yes.
And there will be a few cases
where a value for one angle
will exist and the value for the
one or two others will be
impossible.
And that's also something
that I have to know.
So repetitious as the exercise
might be, the answer is yeah,
you do have to do all three.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Oh, you don't have to
do different permutations.
That's just a question
of labeling.
OK?
So n with a 2 with a 2 is the
same as a 2 with an n with a 2
is the same as a 2
with a 2 with an
n, that's just labeling.
So that's why my boxes, when I
filled them out, the list got
shorter and shorter, until
finally for a 6-fold axis, it
would be just 6, 1, 1, 6, 1,
2, 6, 1, 3, and so on.
Just that one entry in the box
where I enumerated what should
be considered.
Well, here is a whole slew of
possible solutions and a lot
of them are
non-crystallographic, but
still possible.
This says that a combination
of a 2-fold axis--
but remember now that these are
equations and operations.
But the only operation that's
present for a 2-fold axis is a
rotation a pi, b pi or c pi.
So I could combine three 2-fold
axes that are mutually
orthogonal, and that is an
allowable combination.
And what we are obtaining here
is a sort of scaffolding, a
framework, based on pure
rotation operations, that by
themselves will be an allowable
3-dimensional point
group, but which also provides a
framework, a Christmas tree,
that we can decorate with mirror
planes and inversion
centers to get still additional
groups of higher symmetry.
So here's one possible
crystallographic o combination
of rotation axes.
What we will use to denote this
combination is the same
rule that we use for
our other notation.
We will make a running list of
the independent operations
that are present, and what we
have combined here are three
distinct independent
2-fold axes.
A solid that would have this
symmetry plus some other
symmetry would be an orthogonal
brick with one
2-fold axis coming out here.
This is the operation c pi,
another 2-fold axis coming out
the front, and this would be
the operation a pi, and
another 2-fold axis coming out
of this face, and this would
be the operation b pi.
Now let me show you-- it's
rather amusing-- that what we
have done really works.
We've shown supposedly that a pi
followed by b pi should be
equal to a net rotation c
pi about an axis that's
orthogonal to the first two.
So let's pick a motif, and for
convenience I'll put it at one
corner of this brick.
Here's object 1, I rotate it
by 180 degrees about a.
Here sits object number 2,
same corality, and then I
rotate it 180 degrees about B
beta, and that's going to give
me number 3.
What is the net way of
getting from 1 to 3?
Holy mackerel.
It's a net 180-degree
rotation about c pi.
It really works.
Or I could do the operations
in a different order.
I could rotate by d, rotate by
c, and the way I get from the
first to the third is
a rotation a pi.
So that is a self consistent
set of rotation axes.
That is 2, 2, 2.
Let me do one more.
Well, no, let me take a break
here and let you absorb all
this, and then we'll look at
some remaining ones, and this
will include some that are
non- crystallographic.
And that's perfectly OK.
But they're lovely groups, they
constitute groups, but
they won't be groups
that can occur in
combination with a lattice.